[Music]
good morning everyone and you know
thanks for joining us in for this talk
today I'm Dixon I am currently a final
year student in NUS doing computer
science and we have sorry and I'm so we
was sort of there's and we also have
along with me today is also contra he is
the founder of these abilities and we
are sort of working together on the
accessibility initiative here in
Southeast Asia and also today
unfortunately he couldn't join us is a
young from grad so he's on grabs
first-line coder so let me just start
off by talking about what is a 1 1 y or
so even 1y you know stands for it's an
acronym for accessibility that is meant
to fit into four characters it's meant
to fit in more easily into a tweet and
it's used pretty widely in the
accessibility community so I'm also
pretty active on Twitter as well so
accessibility is like simply put it's
the practice of making your product or
service as usable by as many people as
possible so in the context of a website
it could be ensuring that it works well
for let's see someone who is visually
impaired using a screen reader software
which other soon demonstrate or someone
using or ensuring that this responsively
designed for someone using screen
magnification or someone using a mobile
device so to give you a better sense of
what this is about of demonstrate how I
will use a screen reader to access a
particular to look up information on
JavaScript or map function
so a screen reader is a software that
reads out the contents of the screen so
let me just demonstrate by Midway to be
written written regularly right
NVDA menu will not meet us and need
Google data Google Documents so this is
what right now what I want to do is to
use Google to search for information on
e on JavaScript map function and to add
the sort of bottom right is a printed
transcript of what it's speaking so this
is roughly what it sounds like and it
provides keystrokes that I can
efficiently use to move to various
structural elements of the page so in
this case I want to move immediately to
the search box
noting landmark search combo bar to the
left and autocomplete editable and then
I can just start typing
yay-hey-hey beauty okay
James clerk Maxwell's Oh incidentally
[Music]
it's started talking because the page
has finished loading so what I typically
do for increase like productivity is to
listen to at a faster rate so this is
all possible because it uses a
synthesized voice so you can get used to
how it pronounces certain sentences or
phrases or words with me alright so here
I am at the top of the page and here I
know that Google users the level
headings to sort it users that head
level headings as titles of each search
results so I can immediately go to the
first flat level hitting that I find
let's say I can also move to the next
one
right so I'm a fan of mdn so I'm just
going to go into this page
and let's see if his okay so it's it's
finished loading and I can say what I
typically do on an unfamiliar web page
is to try to move to the first heading
that I find so in this case I am here on
the mean height of the piece so I can go
down and start reading so this is the
syntax of the map function and I can
also have move slower using sort of
moving by word you know because
sometimes the parameters can be a bit
more complex so this is like roughly you
know how a screen reader works so I hope
that this gives you a better idea of how
the screen video user would perceive or
use your website right so why is you
know accessibility important so imagine
you're in your you know everyday life
not having convenient or easy access to
information that you need or not being
able to you know perform some activities
for your daily life so some examples for
myself could be you know not being able
to conveniently use an i banking website
because it doesn't work well or doesn't
use good HTML so I actually personally
experienced this problem on one of the
local banking websites you know some
other examples it would be not having
sort of convenient access to integrated
development environments which really I
would love to use them because it really
improves your your productivity but it
doesn't work well with a screen reader
typically
as well as you know not being able or as
well as perhaps you know booking and
uber or grab so some of these are
activities I find more challenging than
others but but I'm you know s soft we
have a great table like mainstream
awareness of how people will use your
various products and services I do see
this changing so one thing is that when
I'm using a new product or service
especially if you are using some
alternative interface to accept to
access it whether it sort of works for
you is something that it's foremost in
your mind so I would like to pass on the
remaining time to demo so I just wanted
a quick poll at the same time
can you show can I have a show of hands
who saw a screen reader you know in the
flesh for the first time all right keep
your hands there who knows for those who
know what a 1 1 y or web accessibility
is keep your hands raised the rest put
it down all right sorry the lights -
right okay and then keep your hands up
only if you've worked on a web
accessibility project yourself before
all right so that's only a really really
small helpful I'm gonna speak to you
guys as well all right so I think you
know I just wanted to share a little bit
more the non-technical side for me it's
a little bit more than advocacy side to
really share why web accessibility is
really important and why we need it in
the region because it's almost
non-existent here so the first thing
that I would like to talk about is you
know screen readers or web accessibility
is really beneficial for some
like Dickson or gang who's not here
today so young is grabs first blind
quarter and Dixon is any rescue of
Computing's first visually impaired
student you know we clearly can see why
it will benefit them in terms of work
and studies but why we benefit us who
are not blind or visually impaired right
and the this is concept I would like to
introduce which is also called inclusive
design which is that when we design are
built for the extreme in you know in
essence we can design for more because
when we take reference from such
different lives that daily leads to
fresh experiences that we can build for
our customers and even more so some of
the examples that I have here for
example I think voice UI is a really big
one now and you know the likes of Amazon
and hippo and the rest have actually
looked towards how blind people actually
live their lives and interact with with
audio cues in order to come up with
fresh experiences on that and GPS on the
other hand maybe not so much the
satellite imagery but the user interface
and how we get navigated they were so so
pioneered by someone who was blind and
lastly of course you know OCR optical
character recognition that benefits
someone like Dixon when his professors
just send out PDFs of scanned pages of
text books that he can't read or see a
benefits him but at the same time we are
also using it for a lot of you know
security applications as well so just to
give you a little bit of a snapshot of
who does a 1:1 why or accessibility
these are some of the companies up there
Apple has been doing it for 27 years and
ok so if you if you look at the the
first three rows they're all no original
they are not companies they were started
in the region there's only one company
right at the bottom which is grab who
started in a region that actually
focuses on accessibility so how about
all the other startups the especially
the mature startups in the region are we
looking at accessibility if Dixon wants
to buy groceries from Vermont can he do
that you know or always be so on and so
forth
so that's what we wanted to encourage at
the same time so apart from companies if
we look across geography geographical
boundaries in the EU earlier last year
it was made a legislative mandate that
all governmental websites need to be web
accessible and because it was so
successful then they said you know why
not let's just extend it to mobile apps
as well for governmental services and so
that's the law of the land at the moment
so in sorry yeah
and in in the US I think it's also a
little bit of a different take something
really interesting that that I would
like to share is in the u.s. if you're a
person with a disability and you like a
particular service but it's not websites
about to you you can partner up with a
lawyer to sue the company and the
company cannot come to sue they can only
comply so this has been the story of how
companies like Airbnb and the rest have
you know started on the accessibility
journey about three months ago blind
people's to mass comm because they say
we want to find love as well so that's
that's the level in which you know
there's there's such support for web
accessibility but how about in the
Southeast Asian region I think it is
severely lacking if you go into the web
sites of any company that started in
this region and you try to learn how to
use a screen reader like Dickson does
you realize that for people with visual
impairment you can't access the
information and in an age where some
people believe internet to be a basic
human right that's just not fair to them
right so what we've decided to do is
essentially start a a one on why I
initiated in Southeast Asia where we are
looking to get web developers across the
region starting in Singapore who would
express an interest to learn about web
accessibility how to do the audience how
to do the the fixtures for the
accessibility
and to comply with the global standards
for the web accessibility initiative so
if this is something that you'll be
interested in essentially we would you
come in at zero experience we teach you
you can take it back to your companies
but at the same time we'll go a little
bit rope we will form little teams and
investigating all the different
companies and and help them with the
accessibility as well so if there's
something they are interested in you can
come and speak to us and at the same
time with zero experience if you want to
learn how to do web accessibility we're
also having a workshop tomorrow at 1:30
if you want to join us and you know we
have lots of fun so thank you
[Applause]
[Music]